i feel like the primary election uh just
finished professor kenneth miller from
unlv is here to talk about as we look
ahead to the general election
all the funding that is uh filing in
campaign funding the ad revenue the
commercials are relentless uh what are
you seeing in terms of where the money
is coming from and and where it's going
already here in nevada
well i think all you're right the
advertising is already relentless but
what i'm seeing suggests that it's going
to get even more relentless that the
spending that we've seen so far is just
the tip of the iceberg
so
if we look back to previous election
cycles where we had races in nevada that
were similar to this one in terms of how
close they were and what was at stake
nationally for them
where
we're not even close to how much money
we're going to see eventually think back
to uh 2018 jackie rosen runs against
dean heller and in that race there was
65 million was spent on jackie rosen's
side and 38 million on dean heller's
side two-thirds of that money came from
outside groups that is independent
expenditure groups and that's probably
what we're going to see here again this
time anywhere from two-thirds maybe as
much as three-fourths of the money is
going to come from these national
independent expenditure organizations in
terms of how much is going to be spent
2020 we saw even more than 2018 in terms
of spending where
races like this one had about a hundred
million dollars spent on average
so we're not even close to that yet so
if you think you've seen a lot of
political messaging so far just wait
until you get to labor day
i'm sure most viewers will find that uh
profoundly fantastic um
you know that i guess that that speaks
not only to um
you know for those of us in nevada it's
an important race obviously but for if
these national organizations are
stepping in they see nevada as very
important that's always that's been the
case for the last several cycles
is it just the senate race or the
governor's race that's getting all the
attention or
does the money assign that it's it's
those congressional races too that are
going to get a lot of the focus and a
lot of the money
yeah we're going to start to see more on
the house races soon uh most likely
we have several house races this year
that are going to be very close
we have dina titus's seat used to be
very safe seat for her it's not as safe
anymore so she's going to need to
campaign she has mark roberson running
against her who he's probably going to
draw some money and he's going to be
active
we have of course suzy lee and april
becker that's already a pretty active
race and that's going to get even more
so
we haven't seen much uh from nevada 4
yet but that's
partially because we're here in uh the
southern part of the state so we don't
see as much of that activity but three
out of four of our house races
are going to be in the ballpark of close
and two of them should be very close
we're going to see a lot there
the senate race is going to be the
biggest one though in terms of spending
national outside groups are most
interested in that they're frankly
they're more interested in the senate
seat than they are who's sitting in the
governor's mansion up in carson city
this i don't know this is too much of a
stretch but what does it say about the
state of affairs and politics in general
when a state like nevada
can draw in so much
money for political races that there's
this much
there's this much money in advertising
period that millions of dollars maybe
it's not it's not new but it just seems
like it just exponentially gets bigger
and bigger every season
yeah and it gets bigger every
election season for us in nevada
especially and that's because not only
is there getting to be more money in
play in races but that's happening at
the same time that nevada has gotten
more competitive so if you were in a
place like
ohio ohio used to be a major
battleground and that had all kinds of
campaign activity going on
wall-to-wall advertising everyone's
knocking on doors everywhere that
doesn't happen as much there anymore
that's that state has slid rather
solidly towards a republican column and
so they don't get as much we've had the
opposite happen we've become a
battleground state so we're becoming the
focus of attention right when attention
means even more money than it used to
you go back prior to 2010 money couldn't
move around very easily now money can
move wherever the races are close and
there's only two other senate races
besides nevada that are considered this
tight that's arizona and georgia so
we're going to be the focus of attention
for better or worse
professor miller appreciate the time
thank you very much you got it